[Music]
giving computers that ballistics you see
is a problem that we've been studying
since at least the 1960s what we want
them to do is look at an image and
understand it the way we do to recognize
how many objects are present where
they're located in 3d space and what
classes they each belong to for instance
this is an elephant this is a taxi this
is a plant this is a human sitting on a
chair and so on the way we do it
currently is with the technique called
supervised learning we collect large
data sets and manually annotate them to
say what each image contains and the
computer learns from this data set how
to interpret new images the reason we
need to do this is because the same
underlying reality can look very
different when observed from different
viewpoints for instance if you're
looking at me from the front the light
will be to my right and if you're
looking at me from behind the light will
be to my left and so on there are many
problems with this methods one of the
reasons is that it's a very
time-consuming and costly process and
the second reason is that when humans
label images in this way they don't
capture everything about the scene that
might be of interest for instance
relations between objects the fact that
I'm in a seated position
probably implies that I'm sitting on a
chair there's a chair underneath me but
more importantly it doesn't appear to be
the way humans or animals learn human
infants for instance learned so much
about the world purely through
observation and interaction this
suggests that there has to be a better
way of doing this so in this paper we
propose a simple method that learns to
understand scenes purely from
observation we train neural networks
that take one image of a scene and
predict what it looks like from a
different viewpoint imagine for instance
a couple of cameras looking at a scene
and we say given the image from camera 1
can you predict damage from camera to
the computer will sometimes have to rely
on something you came to imagination to
fill in the gaps
for example due to occlusion where parts
of the scene may be hidden from view one
of the most interesting characteristics
of our model is that we can effectively
fly through the computer's minds we can
ask it to smoothly move the camera in a
new scene and visually inspect how well
it can predict what that scene looks
like from different viewpoints this work
takes us one step closer towards
computers that learn to understand
scenes the way we do and crucially it
does this without any explicit human
supervision
you